look i don't care what lasseter says the
cat is not my new partner gus don't be
ridiculous
then tell me again why the cat gets a
ride shotgun he gets carsick and you
know this do you want him to throw up
again back there is that what you want
that's not funny sean terrance hello i'm
sean spencer this is my partner gus
silly pants jackson
[Music]
where the hell have you been i've been
sitting on this mop buck in this tiny
closet for the last hour and a half
waiting for you to show up i'm on craig
where the hell is my prize where's my
wrench on
easy now no no i've timed the bowls out
perfectly showing
me then you then me then you then i get
the prize
what happened to not sweating the small
stuff life's too short all that
did you open the bottom of the box why
would i do something like that
that's my ring hmm you know i'm a kill
for that ring don't you
oh you're upsetting me you just changed
my mood from an orangey yellow to a
muddy brown
you need to say something sweet quick
muskem what the hell is a muskem it was
a very common name of the ever
history channel espn gus channel 206
i'm begging you mr guster the dentist
will see you now
sweet me my teeth are gorgeous
you said the appointment was for you
right for me to do some snooping
because i'm a much better snooper than
you are you should keep them occupied
occupied
small cavity it's right on the surface
there's my trooper listen georgie
nobody's in my mouth for anything my
knees are perfect
they're gorgeous you know
[Music]
wait this doesn't track why kill sally
she's hot they're friends
she even heard his insurance probably
that was c4 it didn't come from the
battlefield it came from the south
i saw the crime no i did i said it first
identified the uniform i found the
button near the tree i said it first tap
tap no take backs that's not fish when i
was identifying a c4 sound dude you
snooze you lose guys i don't know what
to tell you
she says she was sad because she died
many moons ago and was trapped between
worlds
when i asked her her name sean
she said my name
is wilting flower i died
without knowing love will you be my
friend
how did you know that i never told it to
anyone before
i was wilting flower gus
i can't believe that you fell for that
i put an old walkie-talkie in the wall
when your dad put in the new insulation
the old indian burial ground you bought
that i got that from poltergeist
or poltergeist 2. kremlin's
no it wasn't gremlins that's not funny
[Music]
sean
[Applause]
listen we change our clothes we get some
lunch and i have to get back to work
gus the plot is thickening sean i've
already missed two days this week oh
fine fine fine
i respect your wishes thank you jerk
chicken you know that's right
there he is
what happened i might have dropped six
allergy pills in your frosty while
you're peeing
you did what where are we palo alto san
francisco
no but close robert's ex-girlfriend
lives up here at gus and we really need
to talk to her i will kill you sean
and then you're going to buy me some new
tires oh come on this is fun
road trip kidnapping that's exactly what
this
is that's it we're not talking can i get
your boys anything
don't be ready in a minute i can't
believe you're letting that woman make
us pancakes
she offered gus tell me you're not
excited about pancakes she's worried
sick cooking helps her cope how do you
know that how do you know it doesn't
do you boys want your syrup warmed up i
don't need it mrs bray fogle but gus
does so
i guess yes you're the one who wanted
cold syrup yeah but i'm working you into
the conversation now she knows your name
i'm just afraid something terrible has
happened here you go
mm-hmm
[Music]
amazing not really it's it's fairly
common for a psychic to be able to
read different species of the animal
kingdom no
no not that what the the way that he's
sitting there
so quiet i mean in in high school he was
always so
loud and he needed attention constantly
and needed to be noticed and he just
would not shut up he was so annoying he
drove me nuts
but now i mean look at him he's so
calm so unobtrusive and the way he let
you just step in and take over like that
i think he's really matured
yeah yeah yeah he has
one of our warthogs is ready to give
birth but our vet is away on an
emergency
could you please ask dr mc
the doctor if as a distinguished
veterinarian he would please help us
bring a new war talk into the world
please excuse while we confirm uh
pumbaa meerkat
[Music]
uh he would be honored yes
come on who's in don't fool around
you know i can't hold my hand like this
for very long thus i get very poor
circulation to the limbic regions
[Music]
i guarantee you that after you hear this
reason you will definitely want to take
this case
i doubt it but give it a shot the victim
was an astronomer
yeah that guy died while he was working
the night sky at the observatory
what would make you think that would
matter oh come on
i know you go down to the space center
that's what poster is shawn thursdays
i'm never done in the afternoon usually
round two have you been following me
maybe sometimes to sharpen and refine my
tailing skills yes this is exactly the
sort of thing i was talking about sean
okay i apologize gus i do but it's all
good
so you like astronomy i accept that this
conversation is over
okay don't go all vincent gallo on me
we're just getting started man
now in the landlord's statement he said
the body was found here in the supine
position
so please if you will sure
just tell me what supine means gus
supine sue
pine you don't know what the word means
do you okay fine you win mr vocabulary
wins
mr vocab is the big winner tonight
everybody
no please please please it means on your
back
i knew that no you didn't
i'm so screwed why he wants to meet my
grandmother so
so you know one of them is dead and the
other one lives in jamaica dude relax i
know like five people that could easily
play your grandmother
okay so you know a line-dancing
octogenarian who can do chin-ups and has
two broken hips
yeah as long as she can be chinese oh oh
wait a second
if you're a guy with an apartment what's
the one thing you definitely don't have
i don't know a horse a horse that's true
answer we were looking for was yard or
garden i would have accepted both yard
and garden i was joking so if you're a
guy without a yard or a garden
why would you have a business card for a
garden supply store
what is rrll
[Music]
rule rule of course
ruler i can't make heads or whoa
whoa whoa whoa i think it's the tie what
my tyler what's wrong with my tie well
it's a little bit
well look it's not like my favorite tie
i'm so glad to hear you say that because
wait
quick give me your time not give me my
time it's a good time ty please
he's the thomas pink time one sec give
me
you